do your angry boss's screams show up in
your dreams
is your pillow time getting robbed by
thoughts of your job according to the
wall street journal which is owned by
our parent company neko wafers
dreams about work are ruining people's
nighttime hours especially the nightmare
where jessie waters hosts the show
yep showing up to a meeting without
pants on missing your flight to a work
trip forgetting about a deadline until
it has already passed or common dream
things
themes or if your cat all real things
that actually happened last week
but experts say that dreaming about work
can actually be helpful because it can
give us insight into how to solve
problems could that be true
what a long day
hey cat what's going on hey greg would
you like this cup of poison i made for
you well that's certainly odd i wonder
if i'm in somebody's dream
it tastes pretty rude
cat you have dreams like that no
of course not what are your work dreams
i don't really have work dreams
uh i don't i'm trying to think if i have
any i might get i get really weird
dreams so i'm trying to think like
what's appropriate won't get me fired if
i talk about it um
i
i guess i do get dreams sometimes that
my husband cheats on me and then i get
mad at him even though it's just a dream
right and then i'll start the group chat
with me and my sister and be like you
know i hear what cam did in my dream
last night and then she's always on my
side she says apologize cam and he
doesn't in any way it's great we're
about five months in things are going
well yes
tyrus you have many different jobs yeah
you ever come have a dream where they're
combined like you show up to wrestle but
you're instead you're sitting and you
have to do commentary
no greg because i don't know maybe it's
a cultural thing but i only have bad
dreams when i don't have checks coming
in uh the only time when i have bad
dreams is like i know charles child
supports do and i got nothing coming in
that's a bad dream
or you know i got i got the third red
notice with cancellation dates tomorrow
and i'm trying to figure out a way to
conveniently trick the electric company
to extend it for two weeks those are the
type of dreams i've had in my lifetime
i've never had oh man i'm so gainfully
employed i don't know what to do
i showed up to work and i got to sit in
a chair and get paid a lot of money to
give my opinion as if it's better than
somebody else's off the street oh what
do i do
this is another
white man's problem first no no it's not
cause i got a lot of broke white friends
this
sorry mandible but
this
is first world problem right and this is
stupid stuff that
we'll call them journalists and studies
they got nothing on the table like what
do we got if uh anyone have a bad dream
about having a job what
it's like telling somebody
it's just hunger pains in cambodia like
what are you talking about
what do you think joe you know that uh
jessie waters said to me that talking
about your dreams makes you soft that's
not true at all greg but i will say that
i know um
i also have work related dreams that
involve uh cat's husband
very proud of you joe
we drive cross country and cat's not
invited
um
but no i have dreams all the time where
i have like awful tragedies and stunning
successes and i wake up and i think why
can't i write one novel yeah
that's really a good point there's a
whole there's a whole
uncharted deposit in your brain coming
up with all
and then i wake up in the morning i go
wow that was amazing and then you and
then it's slowly forgotten that's the
weirdest thing about dreams is that
they're so rich and then they don't you
your mind will not cling to it the way
it clings to a memory because it's not
real rob what about you it's not has
anybody ever had the dream where you won
the lottery and you just became very
very wealthy and then you wake up kind
of sad you're like oh man that was a
dream so i think that this is a function
of people that work too much this is
what i think i think as americans we
work too much we work too many hours we
don't take enough vacation all the
others other stuff so i avoid this by
actually working as little as possible
just doing the absolute least so i never
dream about work
it works
i do not see i've talked about this on
the i don't have work dreams i have
hygiene i'm always trying to find a
toilet those are my nightmares
those are my nightmares and they're out
a lot too and it's like i'm running so
i'm running like through a like let's
say like a weird house and i go to every
bathroom and every toilet it's either
filled with filth or it's missing like a
toilet seat or there's no just a hole in
the ground and then
i'm running out i'm running around and i
can't but and it's just
i had a dream like i always have
football dreams where i'd forget my
helmet and run onto the field because
that's a scary thing because you gotta
the game stops you can get a helmet yeah
do you mean to tell me your entire life
all your accomplishments the only thing
you're worried about is if you can't
find a toilet yes i think i think you've
had a great life
you don't know what that's like
it's like to
need a toilet but you never realize in
the dream though that the reason you
can't find a toilet because you're
dreaming yeah i no i wake up and then
but no because i wake up except to go to
the bathroom
so at the end you find your toilet yes
it was there all along
there's your novel joe there you go i'm
about to have dinner and i don't want i
can't get this image of the toilet
filled with did you not research this
show before
don't go away we'll be right back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else